louis xiv entendrait presque de son
socle noël en plein mois de novembre
c'est devenu un grand classique le petit
jésus n'est pas encore tout à fait prêt
mais un mois avant la dinde
l'heure est déjà aux marrons vin chaud
marrons c'est le cliché quoi exactement
exactement donc moi je commence avant
comme ça noël dure un mois
je suis comme vous que je pensais pas
avoir autant de monde mais écoutez c'est
parfait moi je trouve ça très bien parce
que ça démarre bien s'annoncer
festivités joyeuse la fête
un mois avant les fêtes mais à quand le
marché de noël a ouvert ses portes ce
week end le calendrier de l'avent n'en
finit plus de s'étirer
peut-être que bientôt cent au mois
d'août qu'on va être un train de faire
la même interview ici mais en plein été
c'est fort possible c'est le temps qu'il
décale peut-être aussi quoi c'est la
magie de noël qui commence c'est le mois
plus d'un mois avant le réveillon
la ville de caen s'illumine déjà cette
année encore la grande roue de noël n'a
pas fini de tourner
[Musique]